is around the Manhattan Criminal
courthouse in New York city where the
45th president of the United States
Donald Trump is expected to be indicted
as early as tomorrow morning these
unprecedented charges from the state of
New York could range from a misdemeanor
to a low-level felony derived from a
novel legal theory about an alleged
payment to a porn star six years ago but
today in front of that grand jury the
state's key witness Michael Cohen was
discredited by his own former legal
adviser Robert Costello take a look
I just spent two hours or so testifying
before the grand jury in downtown
Manhattan and I got my point across
although it was clear to me that the
Manhattan DA's office did not want to
get to the truth I need to explain that
a little bit I called them up after I
saw Michael Cohn on TV stating things
that he said he was going to tell the
grand jury and had told the grand jury
that we're contrary to what he told us
when we first represented him in April
of 2018. so I'm sitting at home watching
these lies and I said I've got to do
something about it I don't represent
Donald Trump but I do stand for justice
and I think I have a legal obligation to
inform both sides so that's what I did
so what does this testimony actually
mean for the case going forward in just
a moment we'll review the horrendous
track record from New York's leftist
incompetent Sorrows funded and
politically charged district attorney
Alvin Bragg but first joining us now
with more on what we can expect this
week Trump attorney Joe takapina all
right good evening Joe there's so much
to talk to you about i i find I find
that statement that Bob Costello gave to
Tucker within the last few minutes to be
stunning but not so surprising I guess
in terms of his saying it's clear to me
the Manhattan D.A did not want to get to
the truth what can you tell us about the
charges if they're coming and if so when
you know Janine I mean they're not
obviously keeping us in the loop and and
I've really wrecked my brains trying to
figure out how they could fit that round
hole into a square peg or a square peg
into the round hole it's it's
mind-boggling that we're at this point
this is a case that has I heard you say
novel legal Theory some said um there is
absolutely no legal theory that matches
the facts here there's two very
important things that happen this was a
settlement like any other settlement in
a nuisance settlement in a claim of of
this manner where someone's claiming
they had a relationship but they were
going to go public with it AKA extortion
by the way
um but but that's nothing more or
nothing less than what this was it was a
settlement made by a lawyer okay and the
lawyer subsequently
um create invoices and Bill the client
for much more than that and for other
things but understand this there's two
really crucial distinctions here one
this was paid not with campaign funds
but we're personal funds right if
president Trump thought this was a
campaign
um violation
um certainly or something that would
fall with them the purview campaign it
would have been paid with campaign funds
secondly and most importantly the bright
line test for personal use whether it is
or is not a campaign donation is when
you have personal funds you look to see
if that payment would have been made
irrespective of the candidates uh
campaign here clearly the answer is yes
as as even Michael Cohen was had to
testify under oath when he pled guilty
that it was done to protect the
president and his family from personal
embarrassment so it is it's
mind-boggling that we're at this point
the rule of law is being stretched to
pursue a political opponent of this
prosecutor and this Prosecutor's support
system which is the far left the George
sorosis of the world who who who loathe
everything Donald Trump and so they're
using a case that by all accounts was
was Dead on Arrival by all accounts was
turned down by every other agency that
looked at it and by this District
Attorney's Office who had put this in
the grand jury two years ago and then
withdrew it from the grand jury all
right because they didn't find that
there was enough to bring a case all
right so just so we're clear there is
nothing illegal about giving someone
money for them to be quiet it's done
every day in the corporate world in the
business world it's called an NDA so
when they say it was an illegal payment
let's make it clear it was not that's
number one number two the statute of
limitations Joe has run on this plus
you've got a Manhattan D.A this
thesaurus funded prosecutor who's trying
to bootstrap a federal crime when the
feds have already said it's not a crime
is that correct
the feds have said it yeah the feds have
said it the federal election committee
has has not ever ruled that this was a
violation they looked at it as a matter
of fact Bradley Smith the former
chairman of the FEC said this is in no
way shape or form a crime
um that the the facts presented here
coupled with the the laws are don't
equate through a crime look again this
government official should not be
stretching the laws or should not be
taking novel legal theories
um beyond their normal means to get
people that they think are unpopular or
they don't like or have a political
animus towards I mean one of the
prosecutors from that office left that
office and decided to write a book in
violation of grand jury secrecy laws and
partners of ethics and all those other
things but what he said in that book was
there were so many pearls in that book
for for president Trump but one of them
was that they despised him so much he
despised them he would have paid to
prosecute Donald Trump right think about
that we were both prosecutors I mean
just think about that statement and
those implications and then here's the
kicker
they hated the man so much that they
were looking for a crime to fit it's not
supposed to be that way in this country
it's not supposed to be where you look
for a crime to fit a Target that you
don't like you're supposed to get
information that gets brought to your
attention of a crime and then you you
hold responsible those parties that you
deem committed this crime that's not
what happened here and it's not what is
happening here and it's unbelievable and
now I got to be honest with you people
on the opposite side of the political
Spectrum from Donald Trump are coming
out saying what are we doing here this
is we're going to create a a breakdown
in the rule of law in this country and
Anarchy it's horrible that a a a
prosecutor's office being used as a
weapon against a political opponent and
and Janine you know what happened today
I assume
um the the house Judiciary Committee led
by Jim Jordan says a very terse very
strong letter to D.A Bragg's office
saying we want you under oath and we
want to understand exactly how this
political as they call the political
prosecution uh began and when it began
because according to Alan Bragg a few
months ago he wouldn't have trusted
Michael Cohen for anything I mean he
said there was no world in what she
could envisioned why would anyone trust
Michael Cohen the man's been convicted
of perjury lying to Congress you know he
said for years there was never any
problem with with uh Donald Trump and
now all of a sudden there's a problem
but Joe takapina I must tell you this is
making America a Banana Republic in
terms of our justice system in terms of
the inequity that's going on so um it
just stay in touch with us and let us
know what you hear in this and whether
or not this will go forward but your
sense is that it will Joe
you know I I still hold out hope I
really do Jenny I hold out hope that
that some sort of Sanity is going to
Prevail inside of that office I
understand there's a lot of disgruntled
employees in the manhattania's office
right now yeah I'm hoping holding out
hope that justice will prevail and if
that happens then there will be no
charge because it's a case that will die
on the vine this will be a lasting State
on the legacy of that DA's office so
they won't win this case I promise you
that and you could play the state back
in a year from now
um they will not win this case we will
win it on the law we'll win on the facts
wherever we go we will win this case all
right Joe takapina thanks so much for
joining us tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else